hey this is pressure Locker a servant
has a method to steal wine he removes
three cups from a barrel of wine and
replaces it with three cups of water the
next day he wants more wine so he does
the same thing he removes three cups
from the same barrel that now contains
diluted wine and replaces it with three
cups of water the following day he
repeats this one more time
so he has drawn a total of three times
from the same barrel and has poured back
a total of nine cups of water at this
point the barrel is 50% wine and 50%
water the question is how many cups of
wine were originally in the barrel this
problem is a classic mathematical puzzle
from the sixteenth century can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution we'll get started
with the barrel of wine we're going to
keep track of the number of cups of wine
in the barrel and the concentration of
wine in the barrel at the beginning will
denote the unknown amount of wine by the
variable x cups the barrel at first
contains only wine so its concentration
will be 1 or it's a hundred percent wine
the servant then removes three cups from
the barrel and replaces it with three
cups of water the barrel will have a
diluted amount of wine we know that
three cups of wine are removed so the
total amount of wine remaining will be X
minus three
since the servant has placed back in
three cups of water the total amount of
liquid in the barrel remains the same at
X so the concentration of wine will be
the amount of wine X minus three divided
by the total volume of liquid X
if we divide this through by X we have 1
minus 3 over X it will be convenient to
write it in this form the next day the
servant does the same thing so the wine
and the barrel gets diluted even more
how much wine will be in the barrel when
we already have X minus 3 cups that are
in there and then he removes 3 cups of
the diluted wine so the amount of wine
remaining will be X minus 3 minus 3
times the diluted wine that he's
removing the concentration of the
diluted wine allows us to figure out the
exact amount of wine that he's removing
as opposed to water so we can now
simplify this fraction to figure out the
amount of wine that's remaining in the
barrel this will be X minus 6 plus 9
over X once again the total volume of
liquid remains at X because a servant is
replacing the wine that he removes with
water so the concentration of wine will
be this amount of wine divided by X we
can then divide through and then we can
actually see that we can factor this
term we end up with a concentration of 1
minus 3 over X the quantity squared so
the following day the servant does this
one more time so the wine gets even more
diluted so from the amount of wine in
the previous day we subtract out 3 times
the concentration of wine from the
previous day so we can simplify this
fraction to figure out the amount of
wine that's remaining in the barrel this
will be 9 minus X plus 27 over X minus
27 over x squared this amount divided by
the total volume X is how much of the
wine concentration is remaining in the
barrel I'll go ahead and simplify this
and it actually ends up being 1 minus 3
over X cubed
so that's the final concentration of
wine now we've gone through all this
algebra and I just want to point out
there was a shortcut we could have used
if we had realized it earlier after we
had gone through the first step of
figuring out the concentration of wine
we could have noticed that the
concentration going from 100% to the
first step is found by multiplying by 1
minus 3 divided by X now in order to get
to the next concentration we actually
could have just multiplied by the same
percentage to get to the next
concentration we could have done the
same thing once more when we're looking
at the concentration and we're iterating
the same process the concentrations will
get multiplied by each other in any case
we figured out the concentration of wine
at the very end and we are given this is
equal to 50% so we now have an algebra
problem to solve we have the quantity 1
minus 3 over X cubed equal to 1/2 we can
take the cube root of each side and then
we can isolate and solve for the term X
we end up with X being equal to 3 times
the cube root of 2 all divided by the
cube root of 2 minus 1 and this gives us
our answer that there were approximately
14.5 four cups of wine in the barrel to
start with did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch one
of my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Walker and if you like this
video please check out my books their
links in the video description